it is vitally
important that if God has called you to
witness to a specific group to a
particular group that you enter into the
mindset and step into the shoes of the
people you're witnessing to so you can
understand their
mentality and be enabled by the spirit
to then give the most effective witness
and case for the truth of the Gospel
possible it is vitally important that
you enter into the mindset enter into
the shoes of the people you're
witnessing to to know how they think so
you know how to then present the gospel
more effectively and you know where I'm
getting this
from you know where I'm getting this
from I'm getting it from the Apostle
Paul who inspired by the Holy
Spirit let's go to 1 Corinthians chapter
9: 19- 23 as I said in my sessions I
want to teach you practical application
teach you how to live the Faith by the
power of because I need to live the
faith and obey my God and savior the
Lord Jesus Christ to show him that I
love him and not pay lip service teach
you how to interpret the scriptures and
how to refute attacks against the truth
yes Pedro 1 Corinthians chapter 9: 19-
23 exactly Hab 1 Corinthians chapter 9:
19-
23 let's explain what Paul meant and
what Paul did not mean exactly snow
leopard when he was dealing with the
Athenians he quoted their Greek
philosophers and pagans and Poets guys
do pay attention to this this is
inspired by the spirit listen to what
the spirit had Paul write for though I
am free I am free of of the world I am
free from Satan I am free from sin I'm
free from lust I'm not imprisoned by sin
Satan in the world I'm a slave of Jesus
Christ a slave of righteousness a slave
of the Holy Spirit though I am a I'm
free from all people I have made myself
the slave to all I have willfully
voluntarily made myself a slave to
mankind for the glory of Jesus Christ
for his sake so that I may gain as many
people as possible now notice what he
says to the Jews I became as a
Jew in order to gain Jews to those under
the law I became as under the law though
I myself am not under the law in order
to gain those under the law I'm going to
explain what he means and what he
doesn't mean in a minute to those
without law I became as was without law
although I am not without law I am under
the law I have a law that Jesus has
command me commanded me to obey by the
power of the holy spirit so I'm not
Lawless I don't live lawlessly I am
under the law of Jesus Christ and by the
power of the Holy Spirit I strive to
obey the commands of Jesus Christ right
although I'm not without law toward God
but under the law toward Christ in order
to gain those without law I'm going to
explain what he means in a
minute now watch
this there goes my voice rebuke Satan in
Jesus name to the weak I became weak in
order to gain the weak I have become all
things to people of All Sorts so that I
might by all possible means save some
but I but I do all things for the sake
of the good news in order to share it
with others everyone with
me you understand what Paul just
said did you understand what Paul just
said you understand the argument as Holy
Spirit ows me to focus and destroys
distractions in Jesus name please Holy
Spirit take over fill us with the Peace
of the Lord Jesus okay Paul is not
saying he's a deceiver and he lies to
people Paul is not saying use
trickery be conniving scheme use the
seat that's Allah and Muhammad that's
Allah and Muhammad what Paul is saying
is I took into consideration the people
that I'm addressing so if I'm dealing
with Muslims and I
know that this Muslim will be offended
if if I eat pig meat even though I'm
free to eat it for his sake I won't
cause him to stumble and I will refrain
from eating pig meat or if Muslims find
it immoral for a Christian
man to hug and kiss his Christian wife
or to hold her hand then for his
conscience sake I'll refrain from doing
that and if saying God the the father
God the son God the holy spirit will
confuse the Muslim to thinking there are
three gods that I'm going to express the
same truth about who God is I'm not
going to lie about who God is but I'm
going to explain it in a sense in a way
that makes sense to him God his Eternal
Word and his eternal spirit and that
word came forth from God and because it
came forth from God and God is the
source of that word that word is his son
and that word became flesh Jesus Christ
you understand what Paul is saying I
will not hide in Jesus name destroy the
buffering in Jesus name father Holy
Spirit please my God watch go say pray
for the connection I'm not connected to
the rotm what he's saying
is I will not lie I will not pervert I
will not hide I will not deceive but I
can express the truth of the Gospel in a
manner that makes sense to
them exactly engage the culture on a
level they'll
understand you with me
there are you with me
there connection has been fa fabulous so
in Jesus name they stay fabulous so
that's what he's saying so going to a
Muslim saying God the Father God the son
God the holy spirit makes no sense
that's three Gods but I can say God is
Eternal Word that became flesh and his
eternal spirit and since God is the
source of the word he is the father of
the word the word is the son and that's
Jesus
Christ
right now that Paul is not saying be
like Muhammad and his God lie and
connive and scheme and deceive let me
show you what Paul says 2 Corinthians
chapter 1 verse2 2 Corinthians chapter 1
vers2 2 Corinthians chapter 1 vers2
watch here
for the thing we boast of is this here's
my boasting our conscience Bears witness
that we have conducted ourselves in the
world and especially toward you with
Holiness and godly sincerity not with
fleshly wisdom but with God's
underserved kindness did you catch it I
will boast and my conscience is clear
because God Bears witness but follow
with me he goes I conducted myself in
the sight of the world and Christians
and God Bears witness if I'm lying
with godliness sincerity and Holiness
not with trickery or deceit see what he
said now 2 Corinthians 2 verse1
17 2 Corinthians 2:1
17 2 Corinthians 2 ver1 17 if it starts
buffer I'm just going to connect to the
router again I don't know
it's watch
here I hope not I hope doesn't Satan
doesn't that we are for we are for we
are not pedlers of the word of God as
many men men are but we speak in all
sincerity as sent from God yes in the
sight of God in company with Christ we
don't pedal the word of God we don't use
the gospel to get rich to built people
to fatten our pocketbooks to live like
serous lives we don't do that we're not
perverts that use God's word for
financial gain and means God forbid we
don't do that but we speak the gospel in
all sincerity as men of God approved by
God inide of God in Christ so Paul was
not like Muhammad and his God and may we
become like Paul who strove to be like
Jesus in his love for Jesus okay 2
Corinthians chapter 4:2 but we're going
to read verses 1 and two 2 Corinthians
chapter 4 verse two but we're going to
read verses one and two now Focus guys
Focus
don't let Satan distract you focus so
you can learn now you're learning how to
live the gospel how to preach the gospel
how to conduct yourselves in proclaiming
the good news of
Jesus Michael it's not buffering on my
end it's buffering on your end refresh 2
Corinthians 4:2 but we have renounced
the shameful we've renounced it shameful
underhanded things not walking with
cunning like Allah and Muhammad or
adulterating the word of God we don't
use cunning we don't pervert the word of
God we rebuke shameful underhanded
tactics but by making the truth manifest
we recommend ourselves to every human
conscience in the sight of God you catch
it so you understand what Paul did not
mean okay but you understand what Paul
says practical application wisdom from
the spirit the Holy Spirit using Paul to
tell us how to preach the gospel and
what did the Holy Spirit say in the
scripture he inspired Paul to write the
spirit says take into consideration your
audience and know your audience and
conduct yourselves in a manner that will
enable them to see the truth of the
Gospel by removing every unnecessary
hindrance and obstacle from them coming
to accept Jesus Christ without
compromising the truth without
perverting the truth without hiding the
truth so what is Paul telling you
practical application wisdom from the
spirit how to preach the gospel and how
not to preach it what is Paul telling
you know the mindset of the person
you're preaching to you do not preach
the gospel the same way to a Muslim as
you do a Jehovah
Witness clear
you want to make sure we got that point